to the machine uh the machine learning
people I
I also I would say like uh
congratulations you are in the right
business uh but secondly I would say
um please don't forget where where all
this is going
um have a sense that
these are not just noise these are not
just a matter of competition between one
company another to have a larger Model A
faster sort of uh computer uh a slightly
you know improved Quantum something and
all in all we can go in a variety of
directions machine learning is one of
the problems but think about the impact
that they will have on society on the
environment and on individual lives it
could be a fantastic game it could
really make a difference in suffering in
not saving the environment or it could
be a total disaster so please mind your
machine learning uh and um and be a
little bit more aware of the importance
of your job
don't underestimate how